-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show"!
We're hanging out
with Blake Shelton.
It's time for
"The Jinx Challenge."
Here we go.
♪ Jinx ♪
♪ J-J-Jinx Challenge ♪
-Now, to play this game,
we're each gonna need a partner.
On Blake's team,
please welcome fellow coach
and our buddy on "The Voice,"
Kelly Clarkson!
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, now!
Yes!
Oh, I'm so happy.
I will be playing with
the one and only Tariq Trotter,
right here!
♪♪
Now here's how it works.
We're gonna test just how strong
your connection is
to your teammate.
Okay?
We're gonna take turns.
-He played with him last time.
-Yeah.
Y'all played together,
so this is not fair.
-Yeah, y'all have,
like, a thing.
-We're gonna take turns
getting a category
that will appear on the screen.
When you make --
Then you'll make eye contact
with your teammate.
-Okay.
-You'll both count to three,
and then both say something from
that category at the same time.
If you say the same thing,
it's a jinx,
and you get a point.
If you don't say the same thing,
the other team
has a chance to steal.
Make sense, Blake?
Don't even -- just, yes.
Just say yes.
-Don't fail.
-All right, now here we go.
-It's already a stupid game.
-Now, Tariq --
Please just don't say it.
Blake, just -- you can think it,
just don't say it out loud.
Tariq and I are up first,
and we'll show you
how it's done.
What is the first category?
Okay.
Olympic Event.
Olympic -- Tariq,
you watch the Olympics, right?
-Mm-hmm.
-Olympic event, okay?
Think of an Olympic event.
One, two, three.
-Javelin.
-Gymnastics!
What?! Javelin?
Did you say javelin?
Did you think it was javelin?
-Javelin.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, let's win.
-Here we go, guys.
You make eye contact.
-Okay.
Then do we count?
-Yeah, you count.
-Okay, okay.
One, two, three.
-Archery.
-Curling.
-What?!
[ Buzzer ]
We're "The Voice."
-But I've done archery
on my own.
-Archery.
-Archery?
[ Laughter ]
-We're not thinking of hunting!
-It said Olympics!
-Archery?!
Okay, Robin Hood.
[ Laughter ]
-Let's change -- Let's change
to a different subject.
With a different subject,
we'll try it again.
-We're gonna fail.
-But this time, it's your turn.
-Oh, my gosh.
-You guys go first.
A different category.
The category is...
"Cowboy Accessory."
What's a cowboy accessory?
You guys go.
-Okay, a cowboy thing.
-Ready?
-Okay.
One, two, three.
-Horse.
-Spurs.
Spurs!
-What?
A horse!
A horse?!
-And she said spurs!
-Wait. Is a horse an accessory?
What are you talking --
-Just because something happened
with me and Suzie,
doesn't mean I'm thinking --
-I'm trying to do things
that connect to "The Voice."
-What is a cowboy --
cowboy accessory.
Oh, my gosh. Ready?
-One, two, three!
-Chaps!
-Boots!
[ Buzzer ]
-What did you say?
-I heard boot.
-[ Laughing ]
Chaps.
-Chaps?!
Oh, my God.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's what I was gonna say.
[ Laughter ]
-Cowboy -- Cowboy boots!
Chaps?!
-Spurs!
See, Jimmy,
we're on the same --
-Yes, boots, spurs.
You have one chance to steal.
Name a cowboy accessory.
Whenever you're ready,
count to three and say it.
-One, two, three.
-Rope.
-Yes!
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
-A rope.
-You gave --
We gave that one to them.
-Cowboy accessory.
They both said rope.
-We gave that one to them.
-That's not an accessory.
-'Cause you rope the calf.
-This is all silly.
I've never even heard of this
in my lifetime.
-All right.
-Whatever, chaps.
-Here we go.
Chaps.
All right. Now look,
this is the last one here.
Whoever wins
this next category...
[ Horn sound ]
...wins the whole thing.
-What is it?
-10,000 points, final round.
You guys will go first
just because you're our guests.
You have a chance to win
the whole game right here.
What is the category?
-You're damn right we do.
Okay.
-Damn right. Okay.
-"States in the South."
All right, one, two, three.
Whenever you're ready, go.
"States in the South."
-No, no, wait!
What do you mean?
We just say them?
-Here we go!
States in the South!
-Tennessee!
-Texas!
[ Laughter ]
-That's not in the South!
That's in the West!
Where is that?
-Texas is in the South.
-I thought it was in the West.
You live --
You live in Tennessee.
-Straight down South.
-We got to think of another one.
Okay.
-Okay. I got it. Ready?
One, two, three.
-Alabama.
-Ge--
Oh, my God.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-What were you gonna say?
-I was gonna --
-I was saying Georgia.
I only got
the first syllable out, though.
-Blake, we're gonna pick --
we're gonna pick a --
It's a state in the South.
-Yes, I'm going --
It's way down South.
Here we go.
One, two, three.
-Florida!
[ Ding! ]
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-We win!
-My thanks to Blake Shelton,
Kelly Clarkson, Tariq Trotter!
"The Voice,"
two-hour live season finale,
airs next Monday and Tuesday
at 8:00 p.m., on NBC.